because the IBM PC was based around the
Intel chip and because it run
Microsoft's operating system there was
no agreement with Microsoft to actually
supply IBM only so compact went elope to
Microsoft and said can we buy your
software yep that's fine no problem then
went win so I said can we buy your chip
and Intel said yep that's fine
the only problem they had was the BIOS
the
is the chip that links the hardware to
the low level software so what compact
had to do is create something that was a
I'm not going to use that word
it was extremely similar it was very
very similar that did the same thing
right basically what they did is they
they kind of reverse engineered that
chip so they had somebody that had never
seen or used an IBM PC and they had
somebody that person create a
specification for exactly what that chip
would do and somebody else that has also
never seen those IBM machines would then
write the code based on that
specification now and behold you end up
with something that does exactly the
same thing as the original IBM but
mainly we get its so exactly similar if
they haven't seen isn't it yes the law
wasn't the same for software as it is
now I don't think this story could be
done today that created a products and a
company that was the fastest growing
company in American business history
Compaq grew and grew and grew producing
them desktop PCs in the same way as IBM
were and really did make computing
portable and compatible you know
everybody that was using these could
also share their data with other people
that had IBM pcs and it blew the market
open because then everybody could
produce machines that were 100%
compatible as well so although the
original you know reverse engineer the
chip might be a little bit questionable
actually something amazing happened we
ended up with something that was
compatible everybody was using the same
system and we could all share this data
quite a lot the halt and catch fire is
kind of based on the compact store isn't
yeah yes reverse engineer an IBM PC with
me I want to build a computer and nobody
else has the balls to do
what was this machine called they're
just the portable it's the compact
portable yeah I mean compact was an
unknown name so you know the term
compact sort of quickly become
synonymous with with portable computing
and and this 100% ibm-compatible sort of
thing that's going on so yeah really
important and later on compact would
they merge with hpn and the rest of it's
all got a little bit pear-shaped now but
they're a great thing at the time being
pc compatibl just put the keyboard back
on yeah it's really good because that's
the that's the bottom of it yeah that's
the bottom of it you were standing up
like that but at the side then you have
these little chap doors that would
reveal the power supply on that side so
you can put your cabling in there and
then this side you have all your i/o
cards standard PC cards that go in the
side there so you can expand it more
memory or insert our disk interface
whatever and I'm assuming there would be
no battery in one of these there's no
battery they would only run off the
mains same as the the earlier Osbourne's
as well battery technology was nowhere
near capable of doing that sort of thing
these are all full-size components
really in these things you know though
they Shrunk the screens they were used
in standard floppy drives they have
fairly high current draw bankers we're
not gonna cut it
no I was gonna say that the screen is
pretty impressive looking in that
considering yeah these are got a decent
sized screen so so yeah in those terms
it was not bad at all certainly a step
up from the Osborne
but then the Osborne in a similar way
although it had a very very small screen
had a composite video output so you
could also sit on top of it a decent
sized conversate video monitor as well
so while it's in your office you could
have a bigger screen people do with
laptops today you're just connect them
to your main screen in the office and
just usually laptop in the office as
well so we have all the variations of
the compact so there was a compact
portable which is this then there was a
compact plus there's the compact
portable 2 and the 3 obviously
developing as the PC technology
developed then they would later on go on
to create the Despero and all the rest
of those machines which are more desktop
orientated so that's the plus we've got
the the 3 and the 2 and the various
other ones down there
in the museum there's over a thousand
different systems different machines in
the collection
that's not multiples with the same lots
of big micros and things it's actually a
place to begin with it needs to
calculate a private key right will
private variable I'm going to choose red
for Alice there we go
probably could have used more food
coloring it's kind of pale red is that
red